[Musique]
quand la jungle est en danger igor est
le pire ennemi qu'on n'ait jamais
affronté on appelle maurice le pingouin
tigre que deux voies passe avant tout et
les âges de la jungle
[Musique]
les as de la jungle
j'ai jamais trop compris pourquoi il se
séparer comme ça pour finalement se
retrouver de nouveau ensemble en bas ils
sont suréquipés et maurice tu t'es c'est
encore un prototype il reste encore
quelques petits détails à régler
quand le le train d'atterrisage par
exemple on se retrouve en bas aux minces
ya peut-être eu de la casse ils sont
experts en arts martiaux
[Musique]
je ne croyais pas qu'il faudra aller les
aider gilbert mode non je suis sûr qu'il
se débrouille très bien tout ça
plus personne ne pourra se mettre en
travers de notre chemin pour anéantir la
ja mais c'est pas bon je sache f
d'anéantir la jungle si on allait botter
les fesses de ce qu allah
cet été retrouvez un pingouin pas mon
show t'as pas mal c'est gordon
c'est bien trop dangereux maman tu vas
pas recommencer j'ai des justiciers à
poil c'est pas mal
qui ont l'oeil du tigre ça commence à
piquer un peu quand même
les as de la jungle non mais je rêve
vous comptez rester là toute la journée
à les regarder sans rien faire vous
voulez du pop corn peut-être oui hip hop
comme ce serait super le 26 juillet au
cinéma
[Musique]
oh
bienvenue sur alpha la cité des mille
planète
après des siècles de paix de prospérité
une force inconnue veut détruire tout ce
que nous avons créé
agent valérian et laureline vous avez
moins de six heures pour localiser la
menace
de l'éliminer
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
l'histoire est en marche
cette sous et pourquoi pas je souhaite
que
darcy chapman janser ya un genre qu'elle
se mette à pourrir
[Musique]
tous
et
[Musique]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Musique]
à wisches fait un voeu au cinéma le 26
juillet
avec gameiro
ellison kimble à l'homme devait
lannoy
[Musique]
voile et voile et nuit
ces jeunes chez qui
l'aise
c'est
oui
ouais
alors ok
et deux
[Musique]
viout
il venait
[Musique]
nous
non compris les enfants naturels
il il a dit que nous épater
[Musique]
tous
et refléter
[Musique]
damas mari comme
oui ça va très vite
[Musique]
crosby tapeta comme ce type les migrants
avec dix sculpteurs ou baiia buts contre
go également
[Applaudissements]
que de la samain kraby
[Musique]
l'eau
moi le bonheur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est non
déshérités et voir sa femme à abu dhabi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya pas
ok quand un total final de finale
la balle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]